you're an unshakeable optimist is that
by choice
is that natural
i'm sure it's learned i'm sure something
happened in my childhood that made me
that way and my parents are
you know i'm sure it has something to my
parents and their outlook on the world
um or it could be a chemical imbalance
some combination um you know i think
optimism breeds optimism
so i think i think if you have a if you
have a kernel of it
and you and you water it and allow it to
grow it'll
it'll really take hold and the more
optimistic you become the more
optimistic people around you become
and then you become inspired by them and
stay positive because you know
i think it's sort of it breeds yeah and
uh
like you know like mug wise
uh but
but i think where people make a mistake
is
they confuse optimism and blind
positivity okay i'm not naive
you know because i'm an optimist i don't
i don't deny
darkness but i believe the future is
bright and so even now
in these in these strange coveted times
yeah it's dark and um
but i know there's a light at the end of
this tunnel i don't know how far away it
is and i don't know how long it takes to
get there
but i know if we work together and help
each other we'll we'll get to the end of
this tunnel stronger and better
than we went in yeah that's optimism
yeah blind positivity everything's fine
everything's fine everything's good
agreed and that's actually not helpful
because that's actually not true but
you're ignoring something
yeah um but i'm not naive and i'm
cynical and i'm all the things
but i still believe the future's bright
[Music]
yeah